mesdames et messieurs la maîtresse de
cérémonie du 70e festival de cannes
mademoiselle monica bellucci
[Musique]
et heureusement qu'à 70 ans on est
encore à une tout jeune homme et qu'on a
encore beaucoup à apprendre
il est donc espérer qu'à l'avenir
beaucoup plus des réalisatrices
prendront la juste place
prenez garde à ne pas faire pleurer une
femme parce que dieu compte ses larmes
mais aussi quand une femme prépare un
coup les diables sassia son bureau et
prendre des notes
nous avons choisi de donner la caméra
d'or à un film audacieux le portrait
d'une femme libre drôle forte à une
réalisatrice qui s'appelle les honore
ses rails pour son film jeune femme
on m'a dit de profiter de l'instant
présent et d'apprécier si laeticia merci
et nous teste une exploration on va
hurler sa cheville et doit raconter une
belle histoire mais il faut également
encouragé les films audacieux et risqué
et hornoy mention spéciale pour le
premier prix est à 14 réalisée par le
tpo est vacciné jan
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
un grand merci à nîmes ans mercy est
absolument incroyable
merci la vie il pas qu'on la regarde
tous les yeux
m
[Applaudissements]
peut-on se revoir
omega
qui des deux
usa
vaincu son coeur
errant qu aucune
à fès sur le prime voici nous avons
notre première surprise le jury a décidé
que pour cette catégorie
nous avons en fait deux lauréats des
prix n'est et le scénario est attribué à
[Applaudissements]
pour des clients
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
lee
une vie volée du web net
je voudrais remercier tiéti pascal kraus
tôt thierry frémaux pascal lacoste au
dieu c'est lui qui a rendu ce film
possible jamieson la productrice et
surtout joaquin phoenix a fait de ce
film ce qui monte
merci à mon coscénariste et à tous ceux
qui ont rendu ce film possible nous
serions pas ici sans de merci j'ai
essayé d'appeler son nom leur blesse
[Applaudissements]
merci beaucoup je voudrais vraiment
remercier les membres du jury et surtout
un qui s'appelle will smith
en fait il existe vraiment le prix
d'interprétation féminine est attribué à
dhahyane trouver
je suis submergé par l'émotion
à kehl à l'extérieur je ne peux pas
accepter ce prix ouais ça va pas nous
sommes censés ceux qui ont été touchés
par un acte de terrorisme de
reconstruire les choses et de continuer
à vivre
après avoir tout perdu ainsi lâché que
je n'ai pas oublié
merci expectations masculin est attribué
à roy keane
[Musique]
qui sur moi je ne peux dire que merci
ce prix est tout à fait inattendu
monsieur mes chaussures ne sont pas ne
sont pas de circonstances
la mise en scène est attribué à sofia
coppola
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci à tous
c'est à dire que j'avais pas fait ce
film seul j'ai fait ce film avec toute
une série d'acteurs de techniciens et
producteurs des financeurs des gens qui
m'ont soutenu et que je suis heureux que
ça a été une aventure aussi collectives
pour appeler une histoire qui l'a été
tout autant on n'est jamais aussi
intelligent aussi vous aussi fort que à
plusieurs et ça a été un moment
d'émotion très très fort ce festival
pour moi non et pris des 70e
anniversaire
il faut se faire des câlins est attribué
à joe cole kidman
nicole malheureusement ne pouvaient être
des nôtres ce soir je vais accepter et
on se prit en seulement si elle devait
dire quelque chose à leur ai dit quelque
chose comme ça
[Applaudissements]
heureusement elle c'est à envoyer une
vidéo elle va pouvoir le faire elle même
bonsoir je t'aime merci beaucoup
ainsi hogan
j'espère à très bientôt bien que nicole
véhicules s'être des nôtres ce soir je
crois que quand même il faut prendre ma
photo am
[Applaudissements]
mais la palme d'or est attribuée à le
fils de robert clouse ville square
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
maintenant si je peux vous dirigez
puisque après tout mais j'ai emporté
sept films je vais faire un compte à
rebours 3 2 1 et ensemble on va crier
ensemble on va à troyes 2-1
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]